dos nuevas ejecuciones de manifestantes
en Irán acusados de matar a un miliciano
islámico se lleva a cabo la sentencia
judicial para la ejecución de dos
personas implicadas en el martirio de
seller ajamian el 3 de noviembre estas
dos personas junto con otros dos
alborotadores bloquearon la autopista y
perturbaron el tráfico sabotearon
propiedades públicas y cometieron
agresiones y lesiones contra agentes de
seguridad los ejecutados son Mohamed de
karami y muham joseini Quienes fueron
detenidos el 5 de noviembre y condenados
a muerte el 5 de diciembre en un juicio
Exprés que duró sólo una semana según
amnistía internacional esta organización
ha reprobado las duras penas contra
karami y los otros condenados como
Mohamed borogani según el padre de
karami un ex karateca los acusados no
pudieron elegir un abogado
amnistía internacional condena la
decisión del tribunal supremo de
confirmar la pena de muerte de Mohamed
borugani condenado en relación con las
protestas en Irán tras un juicio falso
las autoridades deben de tener inmediato
cualquier plan para ejecutarlo y anular
su sentencia de muerte ya son cuatro los
manifestantes ejecutados desde que
comenzaron las protestas tras la muerte
de Max a mini una mujer que murió luego
de haber estado bajo la custodia de la
policía de la moral por no llevar
adecuadamente el velo islámico